i'm trying not to wake myself
up you just had to make your i was i was
in the middle of making
my punchline about i'm trying not to
wake
someone up and it was going to be about
that
not about a quiet place but you were so
quick
to jump on your little your little
listen learn how to
we're gonna watch a trailer for a quiet
place part two quiet harder
let's do this
oh he's alive it's not a flashback
reed richards
that happened
that they
oh
nipple chills
off the beaten path
i don't know why you came home
there's nothing left
there are people out there
damn
go to the theaters
and as much as noisy as we are when we
film these videos i'm gonna be pissed if
anyone is even chewing popcorn too
loudly yes absolutely
this looks and feels very different it
feels very different because of the fact
that you have like this
i don't know kind of like your
alexandria you know any of these like
apocalyptic movies
always have that like town where owners
actually managed to find a way to sort
of live
oh we got a safe haven yeah yeah
something like that exploring that i
don't really know like
what is the plot of the other this other
than just keep on surviving i'm reading
all these reviews that are popping up
here in the trailer it's getting me
hyped
it's getting me really excited these are
damn good reviews i'm waiting for the
day when the trailer
only puts bad quotes on yes oh
terrible marketing we are going to
explore some different things but i am
curious
like what is different plot or they're
going to be are we going to start seeing
like the p kind of like a
like a george romero film are the people
going to be the villains of this
while also having to deal with the
monsters who are coming after them
yeah i could definitely see that i mean
especially with this road aspect of you
know them having to
travel they don't have john krasinski
with them anymore at least on the
present timeline i have to imagine
they're going to have a lot of
like rogue exchanges with people we
don't know if we can trust at least
until we find
killian murphy and jamon hansu because i
have to assume that they will at least
be somewhat sympathetic
i can't tell if it's gonna do a thing
where it wants to hop back and forth
periodically to memories of dad and
memories of like the day everything went
to this
or if that's gonna be just like one
specific segment but it looks like yeah
we're gonna see the origin of this
situation or at least the first
moments of it and then the very current
you know where we left off last time
emily blunt looks so badass anytime she
see that
moment of her just cocking that shotgun
damn she's so cool
yeah all right and yeah they have to
raise the they have to raise this baby
and
trek across land and try to find a place
where they can you know actually because
their last home was thrashed yeah you
know so they have to find a new place
to actually live i kind of wish we
didn't see john krasinski in the trailer
i think that would have been a pretty
cool surprise
it's not like a surprise necessarily but
i i was
questionable like will we see a
flashback will we see him appear in here
you know and i i love that uh the
opening shot
zooms in on the toy spaceship remember
that boy
remember remember that boy who died not
to put the batteries in this spaceship
this looks harrowing and haunting and it
feels like a really solid continuation
i mean you got like brief images in here
that my eye was quickly able to catch of
like
when it looks like when they're trekking
back across the road they're gonna be
stopping by the part where they buried
their first kid whose name i
i don't think did we learn that kissing
i don't remember at all boy
i think the thing though is that because
the sequel you know
they usually go bigger what i'm
wondering is like this boom looks very
noisy so your theory about are we gonna
be hopping back and forth between two
different times it
sounds plausible because this feels like
there's a lot more
chaos happening there's a lot more
action
pieces whereas the other one there's not
really a a lot
of that you know there's more like
suspenseful really playing into having
to be
quiet and even the first trailer really
honed in on that
where here i'm like there's so much
like thrashing happening here i don't
know if it's just like a
popcorn awesome trailer and the movie
will actually be
slower and have more that that same pace
and tone that it had from the first one
but it feels like the intensity level
the chaos of it all is going to just be
ramping up absolutely and and i feel
like john krasinski has upped his game
in terms of uh
like working with his cinematographer
like there's a bunch of different
colors throughout this whole trailer
that are really eye-catching
throughout this looks great i'm really
excited
the two trailers we got here are awesome
yeah
and now the only question i have is are
they gonna go full on like we are
becoming the saviors of humanity that
one line where she [ __ ] the gun and
she's like there are people out there
worth saving i'm like are you going to
become like
sarah connor of this universe or
something well i'm excited for killian
murphy
absolutely and jamon hansu both to be in
here i feel like we're going to get some
like really cool set designs of the
apocalyptic landscape because there
wasn't too much that we explored before
i think we're going to be seeing a lot
more of because we're
kind of focused on the small town city
or the nature settings and stuff like
where they were living secluded and i
feel like we're going to see a little
bit more of like the metropolitan area
big
more like the bigger cities because i am
getting some of that last of us vibe
there's things about it where i don't
want it to go
too big don't want to get lost in the
chaos yeah
yeah i mean i wouldn't mind like a
freaking gnarly finale if it goes like
full on this like whoa i'd want it to be
at the end
like yeah you would want some kind of
build up and you would want something
that relishes and uses still
all that silence to make those loud
shrill moments
pop that much more because i could see
you know if you put too much of that in
you could lose it to cacophony and
monotony
you know yeah what's gotten into me
are killian murphy and jamon hanson are
they friends or lovers
i hope they're lovers i get them i get
the vibe that they're lovers it really
matters to me to
know this yeah we need that's the teaser
we need is a confirmation
that's the thing it's doing different
yeah yeah what's it like for
gay guys to survive yeah and i would
love it too if the movie makes no deal
out of that it's just like in the very
last moments they're like oh yeah this
is my husband
if we need to introduce ourselves this
whole adventure jeez
i'm very excited for this i think it's
gonna be a damn entertaining film
i cannot wait i cannot wait it's gonna
be awesome what did you think
of this trailer are you excited for the
film will you be going to the theaters
to check it out
sorry if you still live in a spot in the
world where they don't have
leaders open right now but you know
wait till it's available to watch on
your phone
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that
like button last but not least
lance the door i thought of you
immediately upon sitting down to this
trailer because who
could fare in a silent apocalypse it's
you
man you're the person i would want
protecting greg and myself as well
as your lover and child you would keep
us so
safe with your big strong muscles i mean
lance
do you know him personally we know each
other over the internet
okay i mean this man fights fires i
think he could fight
a big creature who doesn't know how to
see very well fights fires and cannons
canadian fires are more polite than
canadian fires are like
they're putting up fire places
you know it's a it's a graduation going
from fireplaces to just
anything else that's on fire in a
heartbeat you know lance
i don't know why i chose you for this i
don't want you to die first in fact
we'll protect you
all during this assumption he's going to
die
you're a donor and i just want to send
my condolences now
you